BTS is overrated and will historically
be vetoes overrated all those kind of
phenomenons I think struggle to be
long-lasting Evergreen monsters Dwayne
Johnson massively underrated him and
Ryan Reynolds and I'm just gonna throw
Ryan Reynolds two incredibly underrated
men
Meg the stallion I'm gonna go with
properly rated I always love artists in
this moment they've had that heat key
and right now you know you can only have
so much heat heat Britney Spears in sync
the baby makes a stallion you can only
have so much heat heat we'll see
properly rated Jay-Z underrated Addison
Ray I think Addison Ray is properly
rated little baby
little baby